[Musique]
bonjour merci d'être avec nous pour un
nouveau rendez vous de dimanche en
politique en bourgogne franche comté il
ya un an presque jour pour jour
emmanuel macron et est élu président de
la république nous allons donc avec nos
invités nous pencher sur cette année
l'année du président l'année du pays est
l'année des autres forces politiques
avec nous sur ce plateau françois
patriat
bonjour nous sénateur de côte-d'or
président du groupe la république en
marche au sénat vous êtes on peut le
dire un proche
emmanuel macron julien au double bonjour
bonjour vous présidez le groupe front
national au conseil régional de
bourgogne franche comté vous êtes par
ailleurs membre du bureau national de
votre parti et puis alexandre emorine
bonjour bonjour vous êtes en côte d'or
le porte parole de la france insoumise
de jean luc mélenchon rajoutons que nous
souhaitions sur ce plateau
un parlementaire les républicains de
franche comté mais il semble que les
emplois du temps des uns et des autres
ne l'est pas permis le premier
anniversaire c'est le moment des bilans
des sondages emmanuel macron il ya droit
aussi sa popularité a baissé mais elle
se situe selon les instituts entre 45 50
% en fait c'est mieux que ses
prédécesseurs sous l'année derniers
prédécesseurs sous la vème république
françois patriat je pense que vous vous
y voyez un élément positif je crois que
le chef de l'état dit lui-même qu'il
était là à la fois pour donner un sens à
l'histoire et pour transformer la france
et que son objectif n'est pas un
objectif à court terme de sondages plus
ou moins fluctuant mais que j'ai
l'objectif c'est de savoir dans le long
terme
est ce que pendant ce mandat cette
majorité est capable de transformer le
pays de redonner à ce pays un élan
économique un élan politique un élan
européen et c'est ce à quoi aujourd'hui
le gouvernement rejette les sondages au
bout d'un an de votre point de vue ça
n'intéresse pas vous les regardez il
faut les écouter mais je trouve que le
socle aujourd'hui d'en disposer manuel
mâcon dans l'opinion publique
c'est un socle qui est élevé par rapport
à tous ses prédécesseurs par rapport à
ses quatre précédentes récessions libyen
les sondages le soc emmanuel macron il
est un peu plus large que son score au
premier tour 25,37 premier tour de la
présidentielle 24 35
je dirais d'autres jouent à grimacer oui
il ya un autre sondage qui est plus
intéressant à mon sens 55% des français
qui sont mécontents de la politique
desnel macron et depuis un an on observe
on observe finalement
une transformation oui mais moi je
l'appelle plutôt une déconstruction
déconstruction de tout ce qui fait la
france de toutes les protections qui en
qui ont fait la france et le nouveau
monde qu'on nous avait vendu que modèle
macron avait vendu une sorte de
modernisme une sorte de rassemblement
des élites de droite et de gauche en
fait c'est le pire de la gauche
et le pire de la droite et notre jupiter
puisque c'est le surnom dont on affuble
finalement s'est transformé en véritable
belzébuth et le nouveau monde un
véritable cauchemar pour les français
notamment les plus modestes et notamment
les français de la ruralité
alexandre emorine de la nuance soit que
le s'est élargie ou pas de votre point
de vue mais macron il réussit sa
première année je pense qu'il réussit
pour pour l'électorat qu'il vise avec
ses réformes
l'électorat de droite au final le
nouveau monde c'est la nouvelle droite
c'est le retour même d'une vieille
droite à la rigueur
quand on voit d'un côté et qu'on va
avoir la suppression de l'sf de l'autre
on à l'augmentation de la csg la baisse
des appels
on voit clairement pourquoi et pour qui
est fait est fait cette politique donc
des électeurs de droite s'y retrouve je
ne me paraît pas illogique et ça ça
participe aussi de la poursuite de la
recomposition qui a lieu depuis 2010 est
avec quelqu'un qui aujourd'hui incarne
cette droite du coup libéral très 13
euros béate qui s'appelle emmanuel
macron face à qxc de droite faire
baisser le chômage c'est de droite je
pense pas que le chômage baisse mais si
l'on regarde le chemin vers la chine
sont difficiles
regarde les chiffres catégories
confondues je suis choyé de pioche
hommage à pat rien
aujourd'hui il est à 8,6 c'est faux il
était à 10 à 12 avant elle et le déficit
du temps d'autres été d'assez de cette
maintenant à 5,7 et maintenant il a le
droit non mais vous savez comme réponse
à belzébuth et à la régression
j'attends du sang dès le début très
gracieux comme la grille et andré denys
refaisons le match aujourd'hui
refaisant l'élection croyez vous qu'ils
seraient que lui aujourd'hui il ya eu en
toile par l'ifop
emmanuel macron serait réélu il en face
de lui aucune personnalité représentant
ni le front national ni la france
insoumis y la république à lille et
sociales il est entendu en mesure
aujourd'hui d'être challenger
d'élections vous consacrez patriat sauf
que celui qu'il y aurait il eu
aujourd'hui parce que je rebondis sur ce
que dit alexandre emorine celui qui sera
élu aujourd'hui ce serait un candidat de
droite
parce qu'à l'époque on se souvient que
beaucoup de gens disaient emmanuel
macron c'est le fournée de françois
hollande c'est un socialiste
voilà on se rappelle d'un côté des
socialistes a dit jean cau organisé un
meeting de soutien emmanuel macron entre
les deux tours de la présidentielle
et puis aujourd'hui emmanuel macron tous
m'ont dit mais c'est un président de
droite alors vous qu'elles n'ont pas
tout le monde mais vous savez ce que
vous êtes un marcheur de gauche françois
patriat
vous vous sentez comment avec un
président dont tout le monde dit qu'il
est chef de la droite je me sens
totalement en phase avec l'action du
gouvernement que j'assume complètement
parce que je pense que la première
inégalité de ce pays
aujourd'hui c'est entre suture du
travail et ceux qui n'en n'ont pas et
que le chef de l'état a fait de la
valeur travail non pas de la valeur
pouvoir d'achat mais de la valeur
travail
la valeur essentielle et je me projette
dans l'avenir pour ne pas avoir le nez
dans le sondage dans le guidon et je me
dis qu aller je me dis aujourd'hui si
dans quatre ans le taux de chômage est à
6 6 le budget de la france est à l'
équilibre si le but le déficit a reculé
si les jeunes n'ont plus de travail
qu'ils gagnent mieux alors nous aurons
gagné
emmanuelle bach on regarde leur ai
entendu c gepa cj régression et tout ça
tout ça sera passée pour pertes et
profits parce que c'est de la vieille
rengaine d'un vieux monde avec les visas
qui ont dit décomplexé le pays en même
temps exemple destruction du pays est ce
que vous pensez aujourd'hui que la sncf
ou que le code du travail pouvait rester
en l'état
non tout le monde sait bien que le col
travail ne pouvait pas l'être parce que
en plus adaptées aujourd'hui au marché
du travail
mondial et européen accents presque la
sncf veut rester en l'état et celle ci
est ce que laissait tiers pouvaient
rester en l'état
est ce qu'aujourd'hui on peut avoir ici
cf qui perd 40 kg à 45 milliards de
déficit le bon statut comme sa non
réaction
c'est pas la déconstruction si je crois
que c'est la transformation positive
nouveau monde contre vieux monde est ce
que est ce qu ont à nouveau monde contre
vieux monde sur ce plateau vous êtes le
vieux monde apparemment brommat c'est
très drôle de nom mais c'est patriat non
monsieur sur la sncf par exemple
ce dimanche je suis absolument sûr la
sncf
bien sûr pour pourquoi laisser les
choses en l'état on peut toujours
envisager des réformes
aucun problème vous ne ferez croire à
personne que remettre en cause le statut
du cheminot ça réglera la question de la
dette de la sncf
sanaa 508 un lien 101 millions par an
vous savez comme moi que la caisse la
caisse sur le statut des cheminots c'est
la seule qui est bénéficiaire dans
toutes les dénonciations
vous n'êtes pas possible régionales
quand on a demandé à la région de payer
3 millions d'euros par an en plus de la
convention pour payer la retraite des
cheminots qui partent à 53 et 57 ans
vous savez que c'est bien un coût
supplémentaire c'est faux six ans
non non non vous savez que l'âge légal
de départ l'autorisation bien entendu
bien entendu est à 53 ça je vais pas
vous laisser vous faire un débat
technique et bien entendu mais mais mais
les gens ne partent pas parce que partir
à 53 57 ans se serait partir sans une
retraite à taux plein donc ils partent
en moyenne à 60 62 ans comme les autres
donc là dessus vous n'êtes pas d'accord
jugnot 12 oui on peut vous être le vieux
monde aussi je pense que là il ya une
vraie fracture le le vieux monde c'est
celui de monsieur patriat c'est celui
des vieilles politiques ultralibérales
que monsieur macron recycle parce que la
seule politique d' emmanuel macron
finalement c'est d'appliquer la feuille
de route de bruxelles de tous et
thatchérien de tous et régalien des
années 80 cas ce serait vous ce serait
quoi votre politique sur l'emploi alors
à vous mais par rapport à ça bacon très
concrètement nous c'est le patriotisme
économique c'est le come on sort pour
créer de l'emploi commencent à peu près
pas d'entendre nom du patriotisme on
fonctionne pas de l'emploi
mais c'est sûr que c'est ce que font les
états unis c'est ce que fait le brésil
c'est ce que fait l'inde c'est ce que
fait la russie sont des méthodes qui qui
qui marche et ce que je veux dire c'est
clic est frappant avec la politique de
même mac on sait que les totalement à
rebours du monde dans lequel nous
entrons où il ya un retour de la nation
via un retour des protections et un
retour des souverainetés ya retour les
foules ce modèle je suis poutine il ya
un rose que vous venez de dire je vous
demande l on dit que et les pays les
grands pays de ce monde font place à la
nation aux protections qui en découle
est aujourd'hui menée le maquereau est
ce que constate d'ailleurs les français
de plus en plus c'est qu'ils l'ont peut
lui et rocailleuse une qualité c'est
qu'il applique la politique il applique
son programme mais que c'est le candidat
du matraquage fiscal et en cela c'est le
digne successeur de françois hollande
avec la baisse des apl
la hausse de la csg 21% 500 euros et non
je suis pas très bien ça est ce que vous
pensez vraiment s'y arrêter de mentir
la suppression de la taxe d'habitation
vous savez très bien que les français
vont la payer d'autre part non pas du
tout et on a fait le mur les chefs du
gouvernement
vous savez liée à bien tenir le ce sont
comme par l impôt nouveau mais la mairie
ne suis pas très fière quand même
bizarre suivant les invitations exemple
laisser écomusée langue qui vont devoir
monter augmenter les impôts locaux et
les français vont les payer
donc vous le savez donc c'est un
mensonge et une escroquerie et alexandre
bonnet voulait réagir alors je pense que
c'était sur le protectionnisme
l'ouverture la fermeture
oui c'est aussi sur l'aspect nation bien
entendu le patriotisme c'est une valeur
qui est partagé par tout le monde
personne n'a de brevets je pense à
donner en matière de en matière de
patriotisme par contre moi ce que je
remarque également pour revenir sur la
première année des manuels macron
première sur un sujet politique c'est
que il ya de la câlinothérapie qui est
fait à la droite
on l'a dit mais également l'extrême
droite avec la loi asile immigration
notamment qui est une loi dangereuse et
ça c'est pas la france a soumis ce
qu'ils le disent et amnesty
international où on autorise maintenant
enfermée pendant 90 jours des enfants
des enfants les enfants seuls jamais
essentielle mais jamais de bien vous
allez c'est des enfants qu'on lit quoi
sa femme et vous prend les cantons qui
vous vous rendez compte renfermer un
enfant même avec ces paroles mais si les
autres pays
tous les paysans 35 jours et en dans le
même temps j'en ai contre m complaisance
vis-à-vis passant de certaines milices
privées un point relais comme ça extrême
gauche d'extrême droite ou d'extrême
gauche qui vont aller les milices
d'extrême droite alors génération des
jeunes d'extrême droite qui sèment le
désordre et la pagaille aujourd'hui que
ce soit dans les facs à notre dame des
landes
que ce soit dans les rues de paris est
ce que sont des milices d'extrême droite
très bien parlant des universités et des
groupes d'extrême droite qui viennent
matraques et des initiants dans les
environs bon ça c'est fait l'invention
versoix génération identitaire on a bien
compris celle du maître côté de la table
face à face à patriat mais absolument
pas d'accord je n'ai génération double
jeu terminé vous
zain droite vous parliez des gens qui
dans la montagne la frontière franco
italienne qui veut son côté rim ans qui
veulent se situe république alors voilà
contrairement aux milices d'extrême
gauche qui kick ass et moi je rebondis
parce que c'était mais vous avez
commencé en parlant des réformes sur ce
dont on voulait parler il ya beaucoup de
réformes qui se succèdent
on verra peut-être d'ailleurs si le
rythme effréné des réformes empêche
l'opposition peut être de s'y opposer
réellement moi j'avais envie de vous
demander françois patriat si pour
l'instant il ya un programme social chez
emmanuel macron ce qu'on voit bien qu'il
ya une libération de l'économie on voit
bien qu'il ya des économies faites sur
le budget on voit pas de protection dans
l'action des manuels battre on voit pas
comment les gens les plus pauvres sont
protégés voilà on voit pas ça alors ne
pas voir j'ai entendu tout à l'heure la
litanie des prélèvements des procès
d'intention
je vais essayer d'en faire la part des
choses un personne ne dit si aujourd'hui
minimum vieillesse plus 100 euros à
duras du côté allocation adulte
handicapé plus 100 euros
déjà les social deux cantons des doubles
les classes et qui sont pleine réussite
aujourd'hui banlieue dans les élèves
pendant les hommes s'est dit qu'il y
avait 300 gr son intégralité jeu là où
c'est la rue là où il ya de l'échec
scolaire ou 6 au 12 9 et 7 une pleine
réussite 6 et la rentrée la plus à
gauche qui ait jamais été fait c'est la
rentrée le plus faible en terme de
personnel de jean jamais une rentrée
autant de gauche je prends l histoire
des apl vous le dites on a fait perdre
aux étudiantes à des kills 5 euros par
mois
60 euros qui vous dit en face ici que
dans le même temps les étudiants
maintenant adhère immédiat automatique à
une mitel pour 278 euros par an donc ça
leur coûte à l'activation obligatoire
c'est vrai qu'on se sépare mais tu
rêverais qu'on aura les étudiants ils
ont gagné par rapport ils ont perdu 60
euros et gagné 1000 euros en tout fini
le char étudiants est-ce que vous rendez
compte déjà qu'il a dit qu'il a dit
maintenant le bilan écouter autant de
réformes engagées protéger autant des
réformes déjà à l'ouvert ce jour au pel
que la réforme laisse ncf activités déjà
80% à l'assemblée et qu'elle le sera au
sénat de la même façon
ce qui prouve que malgré tout les
parlementaires suivre l'avis des
français réforme de l'apprentissage
réforme de la santé réforme de l'unedic
reforme du logement
réforme de la formation professionnelle
réforme constitutionnelle tout ça ce
sont des réformes non pas pour faire des
réformes
et pour faire que la france soit enfin
sorti du monde des vieilleries dévié
attitude conservatrice d'avant pour
pouvoir être dans un monde numérisé la
france et les confiance elle est
confrontée à 5 des filles le défi
numérique le défi environnemental le
défi destruction de travail aujourd'hui
le défi du terreau et l'a5 défi
aujourd'hui est assez 5 des filles
emmanuel macron depuis deux ans répond
par des propositions de réformes qui
sont des natures aller et je vous
renvoie hier quand on a vu le prix d'un
arrêt public aussi bien devant le
congrès américain
hier en allemagne standing-ovation en
disant à l'europe réveillez-vous panache
et à tous les patriotes
aujourd'hui je les fros jour les
français par justin bieber rouge dans
les français les français juifs à sac
les français est allé à l'étranger les
français sont fiers de leur président
qui leur a redonné de l'optimisme ce que
me disent les petites jambes je n'ai
encore vu à midi dans la rue ils me
disent monsieur patriat
n'écoutez pas les sondages tenhave en
formant les sondages sont nettement
moins mauvais qu pour truc président de
la 5ème au bout d'un an faut le dire
quand même l'image en même temps de la
france à l'étranger elle est importante
y compris dans la dimension économique
pour des entreprises viennent en france
et toutes ces choses là c'est pas anodin
tout même etc sont vraiment l'image de
la france elle est à l'étranger
l'importante mais malheureusement
aujourd'hui elle est complètement
écornée vous avez un président emmanuel
macron qui quand il va rencontrer
donald trump va lui dire notamment sur
la question de l'accord avec l'iran oui
en effet il faut renoncer à leur parler
j'aimerais terminer simulateur on pas
dire des contrevérités qui va donc dire
à monsieur trump l'accord il faut le
renégocier vous avez raison et c est
quand on reçoit quand il rencontre
monsieur rohani donc le président de
l'iran il ya quelques jours va lui dire
il faut pour essayer faut que vous
restiez comment vous vous et vous pouvez
imaginer que la crédibilité de la france
ne soit pas entamé comme changer de
parole comme changer d'interlocuteur et
notamment sur la question iranienne
ou quand même le respect de l'accord est
quand même il me semble centrale pour la
stabilité de la région et pour nos
entreprises
vous avez renault vous avez peugeot vous
avez airbus plein de plein de petites
pme également géré cet accord
obligatoirement tenir et on ne doit pas
selon selon la personne à qui on parle
changé d'avis et changer d'opinion
donc la parole de la france
malheureusement aujourd'hui est
complètement un corner sur un sujet qui
est sensible avec un risque de guerre
dans l'est dans les jours qui viennent
julien donc j'avais envie de vous poser
la question aussi on avait beaucoup
parlé d'une fracture au moment de
l'élection présidentielle entre une
france des villes de france des
campagnes est ce que au bout d'un an les
choses de votre point de vue se sont
réglés ou pas c'est bien sûr un terrain
que vous la bourrée à chaque fermeture
de classe à chaque fermeture de services
publics
de votre point de vue c'est dans la
colonne des crédits ou des débits pour
emmanuel macron juste un bout de réponse
je vais compléter sur la parole de la
france qui à mon sens a été je n'avais
pas écorné mais foulée dans le
bombardement de la syrie quand même il
faut le dire
emmanuel macron a rompu je dirais une
politique et une tradition de notre pays
en s'alignant directement derrière les
etats unis
françois hollande voulait bombarder en
syrie la paf est juste mais barack obama
ne t'a fait je veux dire voilà et mâcon
est allé au comptant kong à cet enfant
s'il revient bravo et félicitations
j'aimerais j'aimerais quand même pas le
crime au président de la république
française garantissent la sécurité de la
france
en luttant contre les islamistes parce
que vous en pensez quand les temps les
détails sony que là bas on dépend pas
l'intérêt de la france justement là mais
c'est là qu'on fait la guerre là bas
monsieur patriat patriat des bisounours
et les petites du moindre mal
on a un ennemi qui tuent des français
c'est l'état islamique bachar el-assad
arrêtez moi si je me trompe ne tue pas
des français avant voilà donc c'est pas
grave de tuer ainsi rien si je ne dis
pas que c'est par contre fait la
différence entre monsieur m'a descendu
les prisons de la république française
ont fait la différence c'est moins grave
de tuer en syriaque à france dimanche
nos braves gens je fais la différence
oui je contiens c'est la sécurité des
nôtres avant celle des autres qui compte
voilà allez on est élu pour ça et c'est
pour vous révéler votre prochain matin
je vous dirais bien que vous avez mangé
votre jamais mais pour vous répondre la
fracture territoriale il voire
l'exclusion territoriale s'est aggravée
depuis un an
clairement avec toutes les politiques
anti ruralité et notamment une qui est
tout à fait symbolique au delà de
l'histoire des dotations au delà des
fermetures de classes 300 classes qui
vont être à la rue réalité alors qu on
dédouble les classes de cp dans les
banlieues ce qui montre bien que
monsieur macron avec une préférence pour
une certaine france et moi je parlerai
de mon département de l'yonne où 27
classes sont fermées cette année avec
des conditions extrêmement difficiles
pour les parents d'élèves
les élèves et pillé l'autre monsieur
totalement injuste et totalement
inefficace et qui va matraquer les
français la ruralité c'est la limitation
à 80 km/heure sur nos routes
matraqué ce que le mot n'est pas trop
vous avec les radars embarqués
avec la multiplication des radars qui va
être qui va aller de pair bien sûr
qu'ils vont être matraque et avec aucune
efficacité pour lutter contre la
différenciation est ce que ça veut dire
quel manuel macron donc on dit qu'il est
le président des villes le président des
diplômés il ne comprend pas le monde
comprend pas le monde rural
comptez-vous quête sénateurs etc est un
élu rural est ce que ça veut dire que
madame mâcon comprend pas le monde leur
a essayé de reprendre j'ai entendu que
j'entends toutes les anciennes toutes
les remarques
oui mais opérettes et les gens et le
monde rural entendre des justifications
mais je répond point par point
écoutez moi bien première chose à
l'anglais andy baisse des notations la
première fois depuis 10 ans qu'il n'y a
pas de baisse de notation
j'ai réuni les maires avec monsieur
darmanin la semaine dernière il ya des
variations dues au fonctionnement dgf
c'est la première fois depuis la mine
300 millions de dotation non plus jeff
et la dsr monte et le fonds pour les
territoires ruraux montrent aussi pas de
baisse donc territoriaux pas abandonné 2
les classes les classes de l'éclat et
bien on n'ouvre plus d'école qu'on
enferme
aujourd'hui on en fait trop là où il ya
moins d'élèves alors pourquoi les la
pression la campagne aux fleurs le
conférencier
c'est comme la température ressentie à
ressentir quand on vous dit qu'il fait
beaucoup plus froid qui me fait vous
avez beaucoup plus froid c'est vrai
quand aujourd'hui le gouvernement dit
les opérateurs sur le numérique où ils
n'avancent pas aujourd'hui l'état
reprendra demain et les opérateurs le
savent il va les forcer à parler du
numérique en territoire rural
il est repris aujourd'hui la loi sur la
mobilité qui vient c'est une loi pour la
mobilité pour tous les ruraux
aujourd'hui la loi pour la formation
professionnelle y compris dans les
territoires ruraux aujourd'hui la loi
sur la santé demain en peine sur les
terrains où les caméras km heure ça
passera d'un mois écouter
je sais ce que c'est il ya un an et demi
j'ai passé dans votre émission de matin
et j'étais sur mon lit d'hôpital que
j'ai vu ce que c'est que la vidéo j'ai
vu que meilleur et je sais aujourd'hui
moi ça m'amuse pas non plus parce que je
fais 80 mille kilomètres par an que je
les fais en territoire rural ça ne
m'amuse pas ce que je sais c'est qu'ici
je mets 5 minutes de plus et si je sais
que j'économise 3 litres de fioul
une fois km fabio m eur si on vous suit
votre logique si on fait moins de
mordant nouvelle j'entends bien
j'entends bien mais vous ne savez pas et
vous ne lirez contraire mais
l'expérience qui a été mené dans l'yonne
a montré les 90 à 80 elle a diminué de
50% les morts sur les itinéraires
voilà du tout sexy la jeune et donnerait
il est forte polémique autour des
chiffres on avance un petit peu et ce
sera la dernière partie de notre
émission pour parler je le disais de la
recomposition parce qu'il ya un an
l'élection d' emmanuel macron était une
forme de déflagration politique
beaucoup de partis politiques ont volé
en éclats on pourrait même dire
d'ailleurs dans la représentation de ce
plateau que c'est un nouveau paysage
politique qu'on a qu'on présente ici je
commence quand même par vous julien
odoul ça aurait pu être cette
présidentielle pour vous une sorte d'
accession au sommet on parle aujourd'hui
assez librement de ce débat de la
présidentielle de marine le pen dont
elle admet elle-même que ça a été une
forme de catastrophe
est-ce que derrière les chiffres et même
derrière les sondages actuels il n'y a
pas au front national le gros doute
qu'en fait vous devrez soit changé de
stratégie soit changée de candidates
soit changé d'orientation pour réussir
politiquement je ne le pense pas et je
considère que le front national a
peut-être le parti qui supporte le mieux
aujourd'hui
dans ce nouveau clivage y en a qu'on
fait ce diagnostic en partant comme
florian philippot les patriotes oui
peut-être mais la réalité c'est le
dernier sondage de l'ifop sur le premier
tour voilà on constate que marine le pen
serait toujours au second tour de
l'élection présidentielle est mieux
qu'elle serait à 23 % elles augmentent
de données d'un honnête ça sent dans
laquelle il ya presque plus d'électeurs
qui votent pour le candidat de la droite
dont vous récupérez les éliminant trois
nommés ce qui montre bien qu'il ya une
vraie un vrai nouveau clivage celui
entre les mondialistes de gauche de
droite autour d' emmanuel macron et ceux
des nationaux autour de marine le pen
est d'ailleurs la droite c'est bien
qu'elle soit pas là sur ce plateau
puisqu'elle n'existe plus concrètement
cercle et les amis de monsieur wauquiez
ont été totalement macro nisé et le fait
qu'ils descendent à 8 % dans les
sondages montrent que finalement ses
amis participent de cette politique
l'encouragent et sont avec les amis
monsieur patriat vous avez un front
national toujours aux femmes accros par
le poids du front national moi j'aimais
ça veut dire quelque chose
une vision et des intuitions et visions
ce qui est une réponse à ma question
moi j'ai un double but soutenir l'action
du gouvernement parce que je veux que ce
gouvernement réussisse
ces messieurs souhaite qu'il est choqué
c'est leur problème du tout ce qu'il
conteste toutes les mesures et le
caricaturent vous mais ces deux jeux
fait d'emmanuel macro soit réélu
d'encadrants c'est la trace et le
travail à laquelle je m'appelle tous les
jours et c'est la raison pour laquelle
je le soutiens alors je vous coupe la
route nationale et je retourne vers
alexandre emorine pour parler là aussi
d'une autre recomposition celle de la
france a soumises qui qui on va dire est
très présente dans la vie médiatique
aujourd'hui en france les sondages
disent pas exactement la même chose
parce que au finalement le voc s'est pas
forcément énormément a grandi et je
pense que vous vous doutez de quoi je
vais vous parler il ya une utilisation
de termes autour de jean luc mélenchon
il parle beaucoup de révolutions
d'insurrection insurrection civique
certes est ce que firent le mans est ce
qu il est vrai que jean luc mélenchon
n'a pas digéré de ne pas avoir gagné
l'élection et que finalement il ya un
vocabulaire qui pousse à jouer la
revanche avant la fin du quinquennat
alors à 20h01 le soir de l'élection d'
emmanuel macron tout le monde avait
accepté le résultat de toute manière ça
c'est clair
ce qu'ils vont dire ça sont ceux qui
devraient eux-mêmes accepté comment
fonctionne une démocratie alors qu'une
démocratie c'est pas tous les cinq ans
on est un bulletin et ensuite on se tait
c'est pas comme ça que ça se passe
on a le droit également et le devoir
même démocratique d'exprimer également
des désaccords quand il y en a des
accords aussi continue en a puisque nous
avons voté notamment l'interdiction de
la pêche électrique à l'assemblée
nationale avec les députés en marche
donc nous ne sommes pas dans une
opposition systématique nous regardons
ce qui convient à nos idées ce qui ne
convient pas ensuite sur la question des
buers maintien sur le terrorisme aussi
après la campagne très beau ça de toute
façon c'est une obligation morale et
républicaine
quand vous avez voilà sur les termes qui
sont animés pour autant mélenchon a
évolué s'est fermement insurrection il
n'ya pas une volonté de tous et parce
que le lien a été fait entre le
vocabulaire de jean-luc mélenchon et
puis les débordements qui a eu lors de
la dernière manifestation avec la
présence des black blocs tout lien qui
est fait entre la violence physique et
les mots je trouve que c'est quelque
chose qui est indigne les mots utilisés
dans un débat politique sont justement
là pour empêcher toute violence dans la
société
on sent quand même que c'est une
évolution du débat démocratique permis
notamment grâce
au système républicain que nous avons
pour empêcher justement qu'au bout d'un
moment les gens se tapent dessus les
manon les gens se parlent discutent
débattent échange nous on parle de
révolution civique de révolution
citoyenne et d'insurrection civique
c'est par le bulletin de vote c'est
jamais par la violence la violence
politique et les jeux je le dis elle est
contre complètement contre
révolutionnaire pour ceux qui se
prennent pour des grands
révolutionnaires en allant fracassé un
volet social il faut des violences
politiques panneaux à nice par les amis
de la france associée à gaudi les black
blocks la dissolution c'est une vie
d'extrême gauche violent de toute façon
vous pouvez 10 août que des
organisations qui sont constitués
légalement les blagues ne le sont pas
pas d'associer la soie d'association loi
1901 des black blocs non je suis désolé
mais excusez moi vous êtes parcours en
cortège d'associations vous avez des
black blocs qui ont intrigué je viens de
l'otage de la france a soumise le 23
septembre dernier où nous nous sommes
fait attaquer notre marche notre tribune
les gens qui allaient parler sur la
balance ça dit quoi cette violence là
pour le coup françois patry est ce que
vous vous avez un avis là dessus est ce
que c'est lié à la politique d' emmanuel
macron est-ce que c'est lié au moment
dans lequel on mais est-ce que c'est lié
à la présidentielle un an après moi il
ya toujours eu cette formule un jour
dans ce pays une forme de radicalité la
voix depuis de plusieurs années elle
existe à notre dame des landes
c'est pas forcément ce qui peut
transformer l'agriculture là bas il ya
des radicaux autour d'eux il ya des
radicaux dans les mouvements politiques
d'extrême droite et d'extrême gauche lui
en a pas il n'y a pas de black blocks
chez les marcheurs je le dis on n'avait
pas notre vraie jamais donc les choses
les choses sont claires
donc c'est violent sur 10 mais de
vouloir d'appeler au déferlement dans la
rue au renversement du chef de l'état
bien entendu à tous ces mouvements mais
l'a fait à ma grand déferlement des
quarante mille personnes
allez on va dire cinquante mille c'est
quand même pas tu es plutôt sympathique
je trouvais que c'était gens que ça fait
partie d' aller de l'opposition ok dans
laquelle je peux je peux comprendre tout
à fait la réaction mais mais pour le
reste aujourd'hui où l'opposition
fragmentée dans les intuitions
d'emmanuel macron il avait compris avec
toi avant tout le monde que la france
avait besoin de renouvellement qu'il
avait besoin de réformes que les vieux
partis classiques était en train de
s'effondrer qu'il aurait une majorité
qu'il y aurait une expérience dans le
monde qui serait entendu une voix qui
serait écoutée confinement devient les
partis classiques sans humour et narines
minutes d'émission ils sont finis les
particules fines émises ne sont pas
finies mais non ce préfixe ont fini les
partis classiques vous allez récupérer
le ps veut récupérer les républicains
voilà pour récupérer qui que ce soit de
toute façon par contre pour proposer un
projet en opposition complète au sud est
malade et manuela compte bien entendu
par contre moi je quand j'entends
monsieur patriat parler on dirait un
petit peu vous savez l'infaillible
l'infaillibilité pardon du pape
quand on vous entend parler c'est un
petit peu ça c'est la première fois
qu'on n'entend de et croyants ça montre
bien on parlait tout à l'heure de
l'image du président ça montre bien
qu'il habite totalement les habits du
monarque présidentiel qui lui sont
donnés par la cinquième région suite je
suis obligé de vous arrêter ce débat
pourrait continuer très longtemps on
voit qu'il ya beaucoup de sujets merci à
tous les trois d'être venus débattre
dans cette semaine avec des agendas très
compliqué merci à tous les trois restez
avec nous pour la partie nationale de
dimanche en politique on se retrouve
dimanche prochain même heure même
endroit
bon dimanche au revoir
[Musique]